MARKUS KLUTE: All right, hi.
So we continue the
discussion in 8.701 on units.
So this unit is on units.
Why this is an
important discussion
is because it is very convenient
and it simplifies life
quite a bit if one does not
use SI units in the discussion
of, in particle physics,
decays in particle physics,
or cross-sections.
And it's also important
to avoid carrying
around large exponents.
And given, you have
a conversation,
you want to talk
about things which
are order of 1 of things instead
of 10 to the minus 28 things.
And one example is
the introduction
of a new unit for the
cross-sections of-- units
for cross-sections
which describes an area,
and that unit is barn.
We talk about
cross-sections of barns,
or femtobarns, or
picobarns, and one bar
is defined as 10 to the
minus 28 square meters.
Physics processes, the one at
high energies-- for example,
the ones we discuss at the
Large Hadron Collider--
are typically of the
order of picobarn,
10 to the minus 12 barns, or one
femtobarn, 10 to the minus 15.
So there's an interesting
story to barns
and why this was introduced.
The unit came out of
the Manhattan Project.
The idea of the scientist was
to confuse potential spies
towards what cross-sections
for nuclear processes are.
And so they introduced
this unit of a barn,
and they're trying
to characterize
nuclear collisions, maybe an
accelerator shooting something
at a target.
And one barn is a
cross-section where
it's really, really hard to
miss-- so a big cross-section.
In this context, also,
the shed was introduced.
This is not very
popular today anymore.
And it turns out that
this idea of confusing
the readers of papers
or of discussions
turned into a new standard.
So we talk about,
of course, barns,
and picobarns and femtobarns,
specifically, quite frequently.
So this is just one example.
This is not really
changing the units,
but just avoiding
carrying around exponents.
But we also, in particle
physics and in nuclear physics,
use a system called
natural units.
This system is based
on fundamental concepts
of quantum mechanics
and special relativity.
So the idea here is that we
replace kilogram, meters,
and seconds by h-bar, which
is a unit of action in quantum
mechanics, c, the
speed of light,
and GeV, where
GeV, a typical GeV,
is a typical approximate
mass of a proton.
So then, you do
this transformation,
and then you simplify the option
of setting h-bar and c to 1,
you find that energies
are expressed in GeV,
momentum is expressed in GeV,
and mass is expressed in GeV.
That means when you talk
about relativistic equations,
E equals m c squared and all
those things, m, E, and also
the momentum have the same unit.
That simplifies quite a bit.
Time has a unit of
1 over GeV, length
has a unit of 1 over GeV,
and area has the unit of 1
over GeV squared.
So that's the simplification.
You might think that
you lose information
by setting fundamental
constants to 1,
but you actually
do not, because you
carry with you,
in your equations,
the dimension of the problem.
If you want to do a
quick exercise here,
I invite you to
calculate the charge
radius of the proton, which
is 4.1 over GeV, or per GeV,
and convert this
back to SI units.
Again, it seems like we
lost information here,
but just from the
dimensional analysis,
you can figure out
what the answer is.
And the hint here
is that h-bar c is
equal to 0.197 GeV femtometers.
So you should already
know the answer
from previous discussions
in the lecture,
but the calculation is
rather straightforward.
On top of this, it's useful
to use Heaviside-Lorentz units
and combine them with some
measurable units we discussed.
So what we do in addition
here is set, say, permittivity
in free space to 1, and also
the permeability in free space
to 1-- so epsilon0 and mu0 to 1.
When you do that, you
basically combine or tie
the electric charge to
the strength of QCD.
And so alpha, the strength, a
dimensionless fine structure
constant, 1 over 137, becomes
e squared, the electric charge
squared, over 4 pi.
So this is also very
convenient, to have
this kind of convention.
So we'll use those natural
units as we go through class.
In some examples, we'll use SI,
in others, use natural units.
This will always be clear from
the problem we're looking at.